here's the trivia question to determine
the first pick are you ready
yes i am ready
before deshawn watson this year who was
the last player to lead the nfl in
passing yards with 12 or more losses
matthew stafford
that's a good guess
that's a very good guess it was actually
jeff george
of the oakland raiders in 1997
jeff george led the league in passing
yards uh and uh the team
that's a good question pretty much
summarizes his career and it was a year
before john gruden arrived as the head
coach of the then oakland raiders all
right the first pick for me it's got to
be lamar jackson we talked about it
earlier he's oh and two in the
postseason and he has not played well in
playoff games especially when you
consider the the
dichotomy between his performances in
the regular season and the postseason it
makes it even more glaring this year
down the stretch since returning from
the covet 19 issue that he dealt with
that knocked him out of the game against
the steelers that was postponed six days
after thanksgiving he's been great
and uh
this is the time now is the time for him
to step up and show us that in the
postseason he's the same guy that he is
in the regular season peter
show me something chase young and montez
sweat
for all the hullabaloo around especially
chase young
but around the washington pass rush in
general
neither of those guys were double-digit
sackers this year they combined for 16
and a half sacks i think they need three
between them on saturday night uh to
come through
and to really show
that you know they
have an opportunity in this game to
legitimately be better than the tampa
bay buccaneers they're going to have to
be better on defense because there's
absolutely no way with the offense in
the shape the way it is in washington
right now that they're going to be a
high scoring team so their defense has
to win this game and that is why i say
show me something chase young and montez
sweat
of all the names that we could have put
on a list of potential candidates for
this draft on monday the name at the
very bottom if on the list at all would
have been mike prefer the brown special
teams coordinator he's my next choice
because look hey this is it mike we hear
all the time special teams coordinators
should be considered more frequently for
head coaching jobs this is your chance
to carry the flag of all special teams
coordinators by being the head coach in
place of kevin stefanski for sunday
night brown steelers it's happened
before for prefer on a thursday night
game for the vikings against the cowboys
a few years back when mike zimmer was
having his eye problems
the stakes are slightly higher here it's
only the first playoff game in a
generation for the cleveland browns so
show me something mike preefer and do it
for all of your special teams
coordinating brethren
you know i'm going to stay in that same
game
i'm going to stay with the same team
show me something baker mayfield
this is the type of game that you were
drafted to win
when everybody
says there's no chance when all the odds
are against you when you're not
practicing
when all you're doing is sitting at home
the whole week looking at a zoom uh
screen and doing all of your game
planning virtually
if you're if you're doing anything to
stay in shape it's on the treadmill in
your home gym
and so i want to see when the odds are
stacked against baker mayfield that he
comes out and says
in the memory of john dorsey
who brought me here in 2018
when we
stunk
when we were one in 31 over the previous
two years
i came here to turn the fortunes around
of this franchise tonight is the night
and i don't care how
many things are against us
i am coming out at heinz field
and beating our arch rivals on the road
you're aware john dorsey is still alive
right
i'm just not sure of course all right
just checking just like john dorsey
perhaps i could have said
i think back fondly on john dorsey all
right there we go just just making sure
i i wanted to make sure this wasn't the
john dorsey memorial super duper wild
card weekend show me something draft all
right next one for me
mitchell trubisky bears quarterback look
plenty of these other quarterbacks have
legacy riding on the outcome mitchell
trubisky has his football future riding
on the outcome you lose this game
pretty good chance
you're you're not going to get any type
of a significant contract anywhere
including chicago for 2021. you beat the
saints in the playoffs you propel your
team to the final eight
maybe people start viewing you
differently if you have a good game
against a very good saints defense i'm
not saying he will but this is your
chance this is your opportunity your
ship may come in
if you can get it done in new orleans
especially at a time when most people
expect that it won't happen for the
bears so show me something mitchell
trubisky and fatten your bank account in
the process
i think he could show us something if he
played well and lost
but we shall see because if he plays a
competitive game has a good individual
day and they lose 32 to 28 people are
going to be saying like kyle shanahan
like some people who at least want to
bring in someone to compete for that
starting job all of a sudden mitchell
trubisky vaults ahead of uh
you know vaults ahead of say cam newton
on the scrap heap quarterback division
you know in 2022 or 2021.
my final show me
is going to be philip rivers show me
something phillip rivers
you know at the start of the year mike
if i had told you
that the indianapolis colts would be the
seventh team
in the afc playoff seeding you would
have said yeah you know okay
decent that's all right
but you wouldn't have said oh my god
what a great job by the colts
everybody sort of figured that they
might be somewhere between what five and
and eight in there so
being the seventh playoff seed is not
why chris ballard wrote a 25 million
dollar check to fill up rivers
he did that and he signed phillip rivers
to come in to be reunited with frank
wright because
he wanted him to play great in january
this could be philip rivers last ever
january football game so
show me something phillip rivers
let's extend it by around peter because
there's many more we could get to i'm
going to go to russell wilson show me
something russell wilson simply because
we're getting farther and farther away
from those two super bowl appearances he
has a sense of urgency to continue to
build his legacy so many great
quarterbacks out there with one super
bowl win
desperate to get to two he intends to
play for a long time but each year is
one fewer opportunity than he ultimately
will have to get to a super bowl and try
to win it it begins with a game against
a division rival two potential super
bowl caliber teams one is going to get
knocked out and if it's if it's russell
wilson versus john walford
i don't think you want that on your
permanent record that you lost to john
walford peter
at home
at home
uh mike i'll end it with show me
something david montgomery and you know
i know you talked about trubisky but i
just don't have a lot of faith in
mitchell trubisky to play great in the
superdome on sunday afternoon
but i do have faith
in uh in david montgomery who's had
three 100 yard games since thanksgiving
who really has been the bulk of this
offense when push comes to shove and
when needed
uh down the stretch of this season for
the bears
and i think david montgomery holds the
chances of the bears in his hands in
this game you know he's got to make sure
that mitchell trubisky doesn't have a
bunch of third nates he's got to get
yards on first down he's got to find a
way to get five and six yards on first
and second down so that they're not in
bad situations on third down it's a huge
game for david montgomery so show me
something david
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports